[Music]
listen
the coronavirus i don't think for a
second that's from eating bats
i think that was biochemically made in a
lab in china
and they make it and then the people
that wear the masks are so [__]
stupid because the masks are made in
china
they're dipping the mask in the corona
virus send them to the united states
it's a whole conspiracy that i know that
the liberal [__] [__] have made to
try to crash the economy and you're not
going to take down trump
trump 2020. jesus christ we can
confidently confidently 100 tell you we
are not
gay but we can also tell you we are not
straight yeah so
so i just don't know what it is it's a
mix match yeah we're a couple of guys we
fall in love with men we have sex with
women
that's how it wrong historians say
wasn't necessary a lot of historians
claim it wasn't necessary because they
felt like
the war was already won japan was going
to capitulate but that we
did it in order to scare stalin because
we knew that the cold war was stolen
probably true yeah no that's an
atrocious uh thing that happened all
around that we did too but on the flip
side you say hey at least
the world got to see how bad it can be
and hopefully never happens again so
like yeah it's like one of those things
it's like that saving private ryan thing
a horrible thing happened but it's for a
bigger cause you know it's like you
can't make omelets without breaking eggs
maybe that's the silver lining of it i'm
not claiming that is yeah because a lot
of people suffered and it was very
horrible yeah people but at least
suffering in japan to this day
so it's brutal yeah with radiation all
that but you can say at least
maybe that's the silver lining for you
that's what it is
but yeah maybe we probably didn't need
to do it but you know war is war and uh
it's brutal brutal all around and you
did attack us first yeah
so you did do what you did yeah
yeah yeah exactly the imperial japanese
nation
yeah it's set up it's lunch time time to
heat up my sushi
way zhong zhang yeah i mean world war ii
had already been raging uh you know for
a couple years at this point so it sets
the stage
japan at that time was just they were
going into asia they were i mean into
china they were
they were they were they were in hong
kong they were they were getting in
places where the brits
had hegemony and uh it was making
everyone a little uncomfortable because
japs were a war machine just like the
germans yeah no the japan
for you know for a small island i mean
they were running they took over all of
china right
i mean pretty much and they did horrible
horrible things horrible things okay ali
yeah so if i do a japanese accent it's
okay and it's like and it's an even
bigger credit to the japanese army to
take over an entire country of china
because you don't know who's who
we see
mexicans are i'm not even gonna lie to
you even over filipinos my
favorite people in the world yeah right
they're my favorite people too as long
as they're citizens
[Laughter]
i feel like i donate to gofundmes
any time i see a homeless person i not
only offer the money i offer them
food and water so why am i not allowed
to then yell racial slurs at non-whites
in the street
because ask me that because i don't know
why chris
chris because it's like because you
[__] can't
i don't understand why it works you
can't do nice things for people
just so you can be a vocal racist but
i'm giving homeless people [__] full
bagels toasted with butter i know dude
but you can't have earned it though
guys you're missing a [__] point he's
clearly doing this so he can exercise
his right to be a complete
son of a [__] yeah i can't i can't
throw a mask at a nation person say put
this on you coronavirus [__]
no you can't i gave a guy if i gave
literally gave a homeless guy a dollar
yeah if i gave a homeless guy a [__]
you're [__] you're a racist
you're buying a race i can't call this
guy a dollar i can't go on the subway
and go up to some woman selling churros
and say passport now or i call ice in
five seconds
you can't find that why not because
you're so
you're so offensive to my i'm i'm rather
a week before that homeless guy you
can't buy
your right to be a racist you sometimes
dude
and i thought you supposed to speak
english in england
you don't okay different words mean
different things like last name is not
last name
yeah surname i didn't know that
i got to the uk border they were like
what's your surname
i was like sir christopher decephale
my mother when she was nine years old
she she grew up in the korean war she
was walking her sister to school
just cut to the chase her sister got hit
by a military truck
entrails on the streets there was no
ambulance so she had to run
up and get her my uncles right they took
rice bags picked up my aunt who'd
obviously had dad and bamboo haters yeah
don't watch this duck saw more toy
touching
the koreans
[Laughter]
i mean shut the [__] up right like that
when i look i'm like
what does everybody just think they can
do anything now yep because because you
the thing the power of the retweet it
the effect it has on a human ego is kind
of mind-blowing i mean somebody will say
something
and we'll get five retweets and they
think what they said is profound
but really you're a [__] idiot dude
what you're saying
what you're saying and you're only pal
the only reason why you're standing by
that tweet
let's be clear is because nobody's
punching you in the face right because
i grew up in a neighborhood where if you
said something wild
and it was contrarian to what the rest
of the group believed and you continued
you continued to push this [__] you
would get punched in the face
so you're standing by your tweets cause
nobody's inducing violence i've had wild
opinions before
yeah and then someone's punched me in
the face and my head's hit the pavement
and i've regained consciousness and i've
gotten up and i've had different
opinions
better opinions what far do you think
the farts are getting ass here in
certain countries or not
i think yeah well i think that's why i
think we need a wall
is because i think you know outside the
united states
those farts man that's the reason every
time trump's like we need a wall i'm
like yeah mexicans
[__] are dirty we get that and
canadian assets too man
don't sleep on canadian uh don't sleep
on how disgusting
canadian fart could be poutine you know
what that's like that's
cheese curd yeah i want to wall around
all that because there's a wall around
us man
yeah but that's the thing what you were
saying is like the people in the middle
of the country
that everybody if it really affects you
like
people don't care we figure out ways to
deal with it like even me like it
happened to me
i was on the show on netflix and i got
fired for a joke
because there was an international like
competition and
the chinese team was competing and they
fell off the obstacle course into the
water and they called it the beast blood
and i didn't say that
the competitor's name was bin fung yeah
and i said there goes bin fung into the
duck sauce
yeah and the hypocrisy was i got fired
whatever
before that for that i got fired but bin
fung bin fung retweeted the the clip of
me saying that bin fung who i said it
about
was very heavy it's like hilarious it's
so funny whatever he wants to come to my
comic shows but i got fired by this fat
white woman named barbara yeah
because barbara has to [__] stand up
for china
when it's like you're a fat [__] you
have duck shots on your fingertips
so um so anyway brian's dad dumps
my mom and starts dating a woman who
lived directly across the street
she's like bro you can't do that so my
dad comes to pick me up for baseball
practice one day
my mom is looking out the window crying
like looking
out at the house where her ex-boyfriend
is now with his new girlfriend and like
whatever
and she's like crying and upset and so
my dad's like um what's going on with
your mother
and i'm like well that you know that guy
that she was dating he dumped her
and now he's dating a woman who lived
directly across the street he was like
you're gonna do something about that and
i was like
i'm 15 years old i have a gerd what do
you mean what what am i gonna do about
that
and he goes listen don't come outside
i'll be right back and and i was like
okay so come outside because like when
the dad says don't do something like i'm
going to do it
so i go downstairs and i see my dad
like literally ring the bell he comes
out the guy comes out and my dad
drags him like by the collar and starts
punching him in the face
like punching him in the chest beating
the [__] out of him on the stoop
right like i saw everything like he beat
the piss out of this this is like
a scene from casino it was like a scene
it was like goodfellas remember when
like
when karen when like rayleigh odor goes
like this that guy doesn't hide the gun
karen i got the wrong movie
yeah i felt like karen i was like oh my
god so i'm totally karen in this
situation
and um and he and then he comes across
the street he was like that was your job
and i'm like what i'm 15 years old the
idea of a 15 year old showing up at my
house and beating the [__] out of me
because i'm dating somebody's mom
yeah it's not in his mouth yeah it's
like it's like you can't beat up
somebody's dad
like as a teenager it's like guys have
dad's strength it's like we all have
death strength right now no matter how
weak we feel we have dad strength
compared to these kids
it was crazy and then like two hours
later where he lives on staten island
we're driving over the verrazano bridge
we're like in traffic
and he goes you know i shouldn't have
done that right is that clear
and i'm like yeah i know mom knows the
police now we all know that
the wrong move is to beat somebody up
like that you know so
it's one of those things where like all
these lessons i have of him
from him are like okay my dad had that
right intention
but he made a mistake here so it's like
i think back
like you know all things that i can do
with my daughter where like do exactly
as my dad did
until just until that last bit then
change it do the right thing and then
you're good
what the hell
[Music]
who is it it's chris
you're two hours late i know my kid
had blueberry muffins which you know get
her wired
6 p.m would not go to
sleep i'm here now ready to have a night
buddy i need this no no no no no
come on man don't do that i know i've
been m.i.a bro i'm sorry i got a kid
she's wild this month i haven't been out
you've been watching ralph like an
insane person
i need to go out thank you listen when
you have kids
you're gonna understand how much these
nights mean but thank you
right i know we missed the movie that's
my bad
but um we could bowl a couple of strings
you want a ball
i'll call connor he'd keep a lane open
for us i'm down for whatever man
my computer
what are you what are you playing video
games you can play video games anytime
you want
come on dude let's go please
i can't i have uh work tomorrow i have
work tomorrow too
i know you're tired bro but i got you
bro
yeah sure
i'll go now he came around we're gonna
have a good night
i'm gonna text probably the bowling
alley not my daughter threw up
all right listen we'll do this next
month you know how this works i gotta go
hello hey babe yeah no i know i'm an
idiot i know i know i gave her a muffin
but she threw out i mean she's gotta
have a stronger stomach
she wants me in this